[Musique]
samedi à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines à côté des jeux
terrestres les jeux d'eau sont très
appréciés par les enfants surtout en
cette période de canicule sous 38 degrés
les jets d'eau c'est pour quand il fait
très chaud comme aujourd'hui pour se
rafraîchir
pour s'amuser pour profiter de la
famille tout ça mais beaucoup d'eux ça
rafraîchit tout le corps même les
cheveux vient beaucoup le petit saut qui
m bac en revanche de lure il faut
attendre oman et ils ont tous bien bossé
les trois petites week silencieux et
pourquoi pour priver marche eh ben il
faut les bloquer mais après tu avais
[Musique]
la famille niangane est venu tout
l'après midi se rafraîchir le jour jeux
d'eau avec mes cousins
ont fait des batailles d'eau est aussi
un jour plus tôt là c'est chouette ce
sens par les dehors et peut se mettre à
l'ombre et pourra aller voir tout à
l'heure la ferme et jouer un peu dans la
base de loisirs donc c'est pas mal
ouvert du mardi au dimanche de 13h30 à
18h30 les jeux d'eau faire le plein de
visiteurs évidemment c'est une activité
météo sensibles et vous imaginez bien
que depuis le début de la saison on fait
carton plein
à chaque journée d'ouverture on a ah on
a une jauge limite pour la qualité de
l'eau donc on est limité à 300 soit 50
350 personnes dès le premier week-end
d'ouverture ans
on a atteint le nombre limite est là cet
après midi on est à 250 personnes en
2020 une allée de brumisateurs a
également été installé près des jeux
terrestres météo-france amuse encore de
fortes chaleurs en début de semaine
prochaine
[Musique]